- [Voiceover] Let's now tackle
the rest of this problem.
So they say a light-bulb is non-ohmic
if its resistance changes
as a function of current.
Your setup from part a, which
we have right over here,
is to be used or modified
to determine whether
the light-bulb is non-ohmic.
How, if at all, does the
setup need to be modified?
Well, we want to be able
to change the current
that's going through the light-bulb
and then see how the resistance changes,
so what we could do, we
could always measure it
with the setup right over here.
It's very easy to measure the resistance.
So we can measure resistance by,
we know that V is equal to,
we know that voltage is equal
to current times resistance
or that resistance is equal
to voltage divided by current.
So, if we know the current
going through a light-bulb
and we know the voltage across it,
we can always figure out the
resistance of the light-bulb.
So our set-up right here
is actually very good
for figuring out the resistance
of the actual light-bulb.
And so we need to change the current
and see how the resistance changes.
And there's a couple of ways
that we could change the current.
We could change some
other resistance here,
but lucky for us we have
a variable power source,
so we can change the voltage,
we can change the voltage
across the entire circuit,
and by changing the voltage
well that's going to change
the current that is going.
This is a simple circuit.
It's just going in series.
The current is just doing like that,
and so if we change the current
through the entire circuit,
we would be changing the
current through the light-bulb,
and then we could just measure V and I
and figure out whether R changes as well.
So, how, if all, does the
setup need to be modified?
I could say it doesn't
need to be modified.
Doesn't need modification.
Modification.
All right.
And then the next section,
what additional data, if any,
would need to be collected.
Well, I would want to,
I would want to measure.
Let me even do this part down.
Let me do it, part c, over here.
So, part c.
So, part one of part
c was no modification.
No modification.
No mod, I can explain that.
I can change resistance.
I can change,
I can change current
by varying power source.
By varying power source.
Power source.
I can measure,
I can measure resistance
of bulb
by voltage across bulb,
across bulb,
divided by,
divided by current
entering or exiting bulb.
And I know the first part of this test
we were saying, hey,
do we have the same number
of electrons per second
entering the bulb or exiting the bulb,
but from what we know of currents,
we know that the current
is going to be the same
on either side.
You have a voltage drop,
but the current is the same.
And so entering or exiting,
you're going to get the same value,
and even if you didn't
know what I just told you,
the first part of the experiment
would have told you that,
that your current is the same
entering and exiting the bulb.
And so, this right over here
is going to be equal to
the resistance of the bulb.
So I can change the current
by varying the power source,
and then I can see what value I get for R
by measuring these things
as I change that overall current for my,
for my setup.
Let's see b.
What additional data, if any,
would need to be collected?
So, part two.
Part two here.
I'd need to collect,
collect voltage
across,
across bulb
as current changes,
or it'd be as I change
my variable power source.
As I vary power source,
power source,
and I would also have to collect,
maybe I'll write it this way,
I'll collect that, voltage.
I'll write it like that.
Voltage across bulb as
I vary power source,
and I could say current,
current entering,
exiting bulb
as I vary power source.
Power source.
So I'd have to measure these things
and then I'll be able to
figure out if my R changes.
All right, let's tackle part d now.
How would you analyze the data
to determine whether the bulb I non-ohmic?
Include a discussion of
how the uncertainties
in the voltmeters and ammeters
would affect your argument
for concluding whether the
resistance is non-ohmic.
Well, I explained it a
little bit, well, up here,
but I'll write it again.
d, so, let me read that one more time.
How would you analyze the data?
So, what I would do is,
so, power source,
I would make one voltage for,
I would vary power source,
source to first voltage,
voltage,
and measure,
measure what is described above,
and measure above.
Use to calculate,
use to calculate the resistance,
resistance of bulb.
And then, vary
power source
to second voltage,
voltage, and once again,
measure above,
measure above.
See if resistance changes,
see if resistance
changes.
So, we could say,
if V across bulb,
across bulb,
over, let me actually, let
me just write it this way.
All the Vs are cross above with.
V_one over the current_one,
so this is the voltage across the bulb
over the current across the bulb.
If this is equal to, after I change it,
the voltage across the bulb
divided by the current across the bulb.
If this over here,
if these are equal,
then I am dealing with,
the resistance has not changed,
and so we could say,
well non-ohmic,
non-ohmic is when the
resistance does change.
If resistance, so we could say,
non-non-ohmic, or I could say
not non-ohmic,
non-ohmic,
otherwise if V_one over
I_one does not equal,
let me write that, I wrote V_i.
Let me write V_one,
V_one over I_one does not equal
V_two over I_two, then we are non-ohmic.
And we have to be careful,
because the sensitivities of
our voltmeters and ammeters
might give us an aberrant result.
For example, we might be non-ohmic
but because of how we're
rounding in the measurement,
it actually might give us a change,
especially because our ammeter
is more sensitive here,
and on the other hand, we
might be a situation where
we are non-ohmic, but it doesn't,
you don't register the
change because it hasn't
been large enough to be registered
by the sensitivity of your instruments.
So, need to be careful,
careful about,
about instrument sensitivity.
Instrument sensitivity.
Sensitivity.
The rounding,
rounding to nearest,
nearest 0.1 volt
or 0.01 amp
could result in,
in difference
in V over I
when there isn't any,
there isn't any,
or vice versa.
It might not result in a difference,
but there actually might be a change
but it's not big enough to be measured.
Or vice versa.
So you always have to be careful
when you're doing any
experiment in any science
about how sensitive your
actual instruments are
and what the rounding might do
for these calculations.